let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
good wednesday afternoon thanks for
joining me
here on let's talk the tony michaels
podcast
live every wednesday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern
we have a special guest for you today
a lot of you out there on tick tock will
know who he is and
even some of you on twitter have seen
his videos before
i know you have there's one in
particular about a screen door
manufacturer uh that he he has done that
has
traveled around the tweets
so we'll show you that you notice i have
a red hat on today
brand new colors even has the tag on it
it's brand
spanking new just got it we're gonna
have red
and blue they'll be soon but i want to
start a trend and make
red hats wearable again okay
we're going to start a trend [ __ ] these
guys [ __ ] them
we're going to make red hats wearable
again do you hear me
so anybody out there that wears hats
get you a red hat rather it says [ __ ]
them on it or not but you can get the
[ __ ] hats here soon i'll announce
on all the socials on all the socials
when they're ready on the hat store but
let's make
red hats wearable again
let's do that so our guest today
is tom powell jr
he is a tick tocker i don't i don't know
if he considers himself a tick tock but
he's a tick tocker he's got a pretty
sizable audience over there on tick tock
and what he does is he takes comments
and
he gives his political commentary on on
people commenting on videos now rather
that
and and he does stitches too he'll
comment on other videos of
people uh making tick tock videos but
there's one in particular that goes
around twitter all the time and
uh i think i believe he's got about a
million views over
on tick tock it took me a while tom to
find this goddamn video i had to search
all the way down in your feed and you
have a
[ __ ] humongous tick tock feed
this if you want to watch some video
content of someone handed manga people
their ass
this guy's it every day all day
the comment section he is tearing them
apart and here's one in particular
and it's about it's about the economy
and screen door manufacturing and
trickle-down economics so let's listen
to that
you're absolutely correct the entire
theory is [ __ ] garbage
let's say somebody manufactures screen
doors they make a hundred thousand
screen doors a year they employ 50
people they pay 30
taxes round numbers the government comes
to them and says we're going to lower
your taxes to
25 percent what are they going to do
republicans say they're going to hire
more people
but the only metric that changed was
their taxes got lowered not that their
demand went up
so why the [ __ ] would they hire more
people to build the same amount of
screen doors
for more overhead maybe they give it in
raises but then they're stuck with high
salaries if the taxes ever change back
maybe they give it in the form of
bonuses but they don't want to set the
precedence
maybe they buy new equipment but if they
don't need it then they're just spending
money to spend money
most likely it goes into their pocket
flip the script and give the working
class the tax break
now all of a sudden more people have
more money at the end of the month now
families are like hey that screen door
needs to be replaced
demand for those doors go up you have to
hire more people
the economy grows that's how it's done
now most people would look at tom and
look at this video and listen to it and
say oh my god
he's a liberal oh he's a liberal
you socialist commie liberal it's
it's logical it's called [ __ ] common
sense
is what it's called so liber if that's
liberalism then yeah i guess so
but let's bring tom on and let's find
out hey tom how are you let's find out
if he thinks it's
if he considers himself a liberal or
just
you know using your brain well i mean i
have
labeled myself as a liberal in the past
but i guess true liberals say i'm uh i'm
a
republican light oh a republican light
so like
uh miller light or camel light
you know still the thing but you know so
so you're you're known for several
different things obviously your tick
tocks are one thing that you're known
for but
there's a guitar behind you that you're
known for everyone likes your guitar
i think and then uh everyone i think it
normally comments on your beard but also
the shirt you got on
um the 420 is a holiday that you
usually celebrate i i take it vigorously
and daily
well you know it is a thing you know i
think that's one subject we could
probably do a whole podcast about is uh
what what what is the state of marijuana
in our country it looks like the state
of marijuana
has has been better than ever as far as
legal grounds it's always been a popular
thing but
you know you're never going to get rid
of uh smoking pot by any means but
no the green wave is strong so is that
what so what was your inspiration for
this screen
door video this tick tock because uh i
noticed the comment but you said the
screen door factory is there
is there a specific reason why you went
with screen door factory as opposed to a
car factory or something like that
no i honestly was just trying to pick
something out of thin air that you know
people could
see is something that was manufactured
you know uh
something that we can make and so i just
came up with screen door
and the reason i kind of lean towards
screen doors is for the example i used
at the end
you know we've all been i for years my
wife and i were in a position where i
was like
you know what that screen door needs to
be replaced that we just don't have
enough money
maybe at the end of the month one month
we'll have enough money to replace that
screen drawer so that's why it kind of
made sense
something that can be manufactured and
that everybody can see and that
everybody can kind of identify with
now you do a lot of these videos where
you try to break down
logic now rather it's someone commenting
and you're agreeing with him
or if it's like some kind of q anon maga
trump humper as i call them
uh you know saying something really
ridiculous
in a comment section or making a
ridiculous video you know you try to
come at them with uh
this we'll call it liberal logic i guess
but i would just call it [ __ ] logic
um and you found a lot of success on
tick tock but you also
you also are outside tik tok you have a
podcast and you have books
uh tell us about that and then we'll get
back to the tick tock stuff because i
know the people out there
want to talk about the tiki talk uh yeah
most people do nowadays
um yeah i do have a podcast myself i
host one that uh
it doesn't air at a specific time i
pre-record it the day before
or you know just before i'm about ready
to publish it it's amateur run it's done
on this microphone at this desk
and it's basically me for an hour
talking about now
politics used to be just weird stories i
publish it on friday it's
just a little podcast called the second
half podcast and i got two books that
i've self-published self-publishing is
easy
and anybody can do it and i often tell
people everybody's got at least one book
in them
it's easy and free to do and if you've
got one in you send me a message i'll
tell you how to do it
fantastic so he's an author folks
he's an author he's a podcaster and he's
a tick talker so let's get back to the
tick-tock because
you know people like i gotta read a book
i can't hold my cell phone and just flip
through videos this
is what is this this is this is 20 21 i
just want to flip through videos
and have people tell me when i'm
supposed that's why i have more
followers than sales
so let's talk about your followers
because i i followed you for a long time
on tick tock
uh because i i opened my account uh
with the the quarantine thing and i did
it in the beginning
and kind of did a few videos and then i
laid off
and then the election came about and i
got tired of it so i started yelling and
screaming into the tick tock about
politics and that's
where we're at now right now with what
we're doing so tell me about
why did you start a tic tac why even
[ __ ] with that thing
and what led you to the videos that
you're doing now that tick tock has you
in
uh a tick tock jail cause they they want
you
they want you to do a certain amount of
videos right a certain kind of video
we were talking about this earlier oh no
no no i'm not in tick tock jail i'm in
twitter
oh twit that's right you're in twitter
jail okay so so so tell me about the
tick tock though and then we'll come
back to the twitter
uh yeah so i well i got on tick tock
because i am
i got a lifetime ban from twitter uh i
do social media because
i think about this [ __ ] pretty much all
the time and
and instead of unloading on my wife and
giving her my opinion on every subject
that comes down
the [ __ ] pipeline i make content it
used to be facebook and twitter content
that i made
and i would interact with people who
would interact with that content
and it was kind of a cathartic release
well i got a 30-day ban on facebook and
i got a lifetime ban on twitter and so i
wound up on tick tock
i think i started my tick tock account
on december
10th 2020 and i waited a week or two
just kind of seeing what it was about
before i made a video and
i made a video about a giveaway that i
was doing on facebook and
a couple of videos about the christmas
tree and christmas presents
and the dogs and and and then i made my
first political tic tac and then here we
are seven months later
huh so it wasn't started for the
political thing it just turned into that
because that's probably what you were
seeing
what they were feeding you with the
algorithm is that right well
well no i talked about politics on
facebook and i talked a ton about
politics on twitter is that what got you
banned on twitter
yeah i called laura ingram a hag
and they they kicked you off twitter
forever for calling laura ingram a hag
yeah and it wasn't like facebook i had
gotten
a couple of those you know you're gonna
sit in timeout for like 12 hours i had
like three or four of those
just a pause just a pause really yeah
nothing major like facebook like i had
gotten
a month-long suspension from facebook
but yeah so i got the suspension
from facebook in early december and i
was pissed because i had already
announced my giveaway my christmas
giveaway
i was giving away a stash box and a
whole set with my company logo on it
and now i couldn't do it because i was i
was i was locked out for 30 days on
facebook so i was aggravated
i went to twitter laura ingram had
tweeted something stupid out as laura
ingram tends to do
no i
tweeted back at her why don't you shut
up you had
oh well lifetime so
have you tried to sneak back on as like
a different
you know like a troll account or
something like that
because you're on you're on twitter
everywhere your your face is on twitter
everywhere but uh
i have so i started a second account and
what happens is
twitter can recognize the uh the ips ah
i see so unless you go get yourself
another phone a burner phone
so they shut down that account within 15
minutes
right so you open it they they ban you
again
and then my wife gave me an old iphone 6
of hers
that had been sitting in the drawer and
i started a new account and it's
it's like the crazy hippie or the old
old nutty hippy i don't even know what
it is
it's been five months since i've been
back on it oh okay
i'm not carrying two phones just to have
a goddamn twitter
well everyone out there knows that i
would carry six phones to have a twitter
account that's
100 that's what i would do
understandable
yeah well you know i i like twitter i
like tick-tock too
uh and we were talking about tick-tock
before we came on here and really what
tick-tock's about
and maybe we'll talk a little more about
that before we get into the politics
because
i do have another video of yours that
you did recently i think it was your
last video about don jr
that i want to get to but so on on tick
tock we were talking earlier about the
algorithms and gaining followers and
you've got a huge following here just
the last few months it's kind of
exploded
uh do you think what do you what do you
think what do you think makes
audiences explode or your followers
explode on tick tock is there anything
that
you can tell other people that are
making tick tock videos
any advice you can get them or is it
just a shot in the dark
well it's a combination of both i think
i mean but it's it's a it's a question
of
continuing to make content sooner or
later something's gonna hit it seems
like with everybody whether you do funny
stuff
or political stuff or you're in a weight
loss regime or something like that
sooner or later one of your videos is
going to hit and go viral
the more videos you put out there the
more you increase your chance that the
hits are going to happen
i just happen to be retired and so i
have a shitload of time and i like to do
a lot of content
and so i i can make 20 videos a day for
tick tock
one of them is going to hit so usually
every day i have one that gets
20 30 40 000 views and somewhere along
the line once a week one will get a
couple of hundred thousand
right so so your so your strategy is
just to throw as much spaghetti at the
wall
and see if it sticks it's kind of is
what you're saying
well actually it wasn't even to build an
audience though it was the kind just you
know like i had told you earlier to let
people know about the books but
just kind of like you guys are my
bartender i'm just
i'm telling you this [ __ ] so that i
don't tell my wife so
so so it really really the one bartender
turned into three hundred thousand
bartenders is that like real [ __ ]
quick
well you know again the content that you
do
is very popular on political tick tock
because there's different sides of tick
tock different corners of tick tock
and on tick tock you're you're obviously
on political tic tac because you make a
lot of political statements you talk a
lot about
you you do a lot of political commentary
so so but but the stitching of the
videos and the commenting or making a
video on a comment and i think they call
it a comment video
i don't i don't do that sort of uh
content on tic tac i think that's why
they don't like me over there
but uh i i just do you prefer that
comment do you prefer the stitch
do you like to just make your i mean
what kind of content do you like to make
other than what other people want you to
make
well video replies uh are what i do the
most of because it's more like having a
conversation
so you know you start what i did was i
started out by putting out a handful of
my opinions
and then people commented on those
opinions and then in order to have a
conversation
back and forth i either type into the
comment section all of the [ __ ] that i
want to reply to that person
which as we know with tic toc is not
very easy because it's a limited section
right or i can do a quick 60 second
video reply well it just so happens that
every time i do a quick 60 second video
reply it extends that conversation out
because it creates another piece of
content
and before you you know it just me
having conversations with people during
the middle of the day turns into
20 tick tock videos well i did notice
because like i said it took me a long
time to find that [ __ ] screen door
video to download it
yeah man i had to go all the way down
i had here's what i did i i took what
shirt you had on because
because there's something about tom
powell and it's the same thing with me
like i wear the same
shirts the same hats but it's different
time different ones every time
so that's how i find my own videos i'm
like okay i had this hat on and i had
this shirt on during this video so i go
fine
so i noticed you had the kiss shirt on
and it was sometime during the day
so i was like okay i'm looking for the
kiss shirt you know and i'm just
scrolling scrolling and you wear a lot
of tie dye so that was simple that was
easy
but you wear a couple black shirts i had
to stop and so it took me a while to
find that damn video but
i will tell you the next video did not
take me long
that long at all to find because it was
one of your recent videos
and i want to play it because i found
uh don jr he
he tweeted no no not tweeted he put it
on instagram
so here's the instagram uh that don jr
it's mark milly uh you know he's really
he's
obvious uh making homosexual tropes
towards
millie here because he's got pink hair
and the rainbow on his jacket and the
black lives matter as if
rainbow's message of equality and hair
color offends
anyone who's reasonable and logical
anymore
but it definitely it definitely hurts
don jr's white fragility
but he talks about how the armies woke
or whatever and he's he's kind of he's
not kind of he is a [ __ ] but he's
kind of off the deep end there was a
video that was made that he made that he
posted
um and you actually commented i think
someone posted it was patty
panda i think he posted you stitched
this video of him
putting up the video so let me play that
and then we'll talk about i don't think
joe's funny to be like
hey let's send them off the trail
speaking of somebody who's been on
multiple multi-day benders
this dude is strong the [ __ ] out nobody
who's ever been on a multi-day bender
can
look at any one of his recent videos and
deny the fact that he is strung out
and he's losing it and i'm telling you
listen i'm not losing any sleep because
donny jr is [ __ ] losing it all right
but from his inner circle how do you
guys not see it how do you guys not stop
it and get this guy help
immediately if you don't you're gonna
find him face down in some shitty hotel
one day
i'm telling you he is strong out
so don jr has been very um
i don't you know you call it strung out
but man he's
he's in big trouble here uh with the
trump organization which
this leads us into that conversation
about them uh
probably being charged tomorrow as well
as alan weisselberg the cfo
the chief financial officer of trump
organization which to me it sounds like
a pressure campaign by the prosecutor
um but don jr
and it sounds like you were trying to
say hey i have experience on this but
tell me about the video
a little more elaborate a little more
what your thoughts were on don junior's
video there and what his situation is
well i mean obviously you can tell that
this is somebody that
is currently um
like i said strung out i believe he is
deep
into the booger sugar uh and it doesn't
look like he's doing very well because i
believe the realization is setting in
we've been seeing videos like this from
don jr
from the end of the election on
of him in these strung out states of
mine and i think the reality that this
whole thing is over and the organization
that he lives off of
is going to have to come to a close and
he's got some decisions he's going to
make
is he going to jail for dad or is he
flipping on dad
because that's a decision he's going to
have to make in the very near future
so so you think you think when these
charges come down
it's not just a pressure campaign into
alan weiselberg
uh to flip but it's also maybe the
possibly the children and the other
officers and the other people that are
involved in this organization is that
what you're saying
absolutely i believe it's going to be a
ricoh charge that's going to involve
trump trump jr eric trump ivanka trump
alan weiselberg and uh the lawyer that's
in jail cohen
yeah so so so i i believe that you are
correct
in many different ways now uh uh all
over social media people been worried
because uh we heard last week the end of
last week they were going to charge
someone
the organization charged somebody this
week with tax fraud
charges out of the manhattan da's office
that's what we heard and then over the
weekend we
heard oh no no no they're giving them
till monday to rebut this trump's not
going to be indicted
and of course if tomorrow if this is the
truth that the trump organization's
going to be indicted
the cfo alan weisenberg is going to be
indicted of course trump's gonna come
out and say
see i wasn't indicted ha ha ha
nana booboo stick your head and doo-doo
which
to his supporters of course you will
have thousands and thousands and
thousands of videos to stitch
to make your own content and the
thousands and thousands of thousands of
comments
to to uh do replies and to create
content so it'll be great content
creation for you
but i think what they're missing here is
the reason why they're only charging the
organization
and alan weisselberg the reason why
is because they want more evidence
against donald
trump and to pressure weisselberg and to
threaten their organization
with criminal charges which you know
i really would love to see donald trump
and possibly his family
towed it off to prison i think a lot of
people would but here's one thing that i
want to see more than anything
is the trump name come down off all
those properties
that's that's the main thing and by
taking down the trump organization
by making it to where they have to
auction off all this stuff because
that's what they're cause he owes
he's not rich do you believe that that
he's rich
i mean he's rich in assets but he owes a
ton
would be my guess leveraged
right so so but but to to keep normal
people everyday people he's probably
rich
but to the wealthy in this country no
he's not part of the club
right he's [ __ ] part of the club
because he could never handle money
the way his father could handle money
his father was actually successful his
father was actually rich and he pissed
the whole [ __ ] thing away
because he was all about partying and
being some kind of a socialite but he
was too much of a [ __ ] dumbass to get
into that crowd
so he tried to buy his way in and when
he couldn't buy his way in
he became the aggravated outsider and
decided to use
what resources he had to get back at the
world and
here's where we are all these years
later and
and that's the whole reason why he ran
for president don't you think is to get
back at barack obama for making fun of
him at that [ __ ]
the the the correspondents dinner yeah
obama smoked them
in that correspondence dinner and he got
pissed off and he said watch i'll take
your job
what he didn't understand was he
couldn't take obama's job
he could only get the open job right
trump run against obama obama would have
[ __ ] eaten him for lunch
oh well i mean the same way that that
biden ate him for lunch
yeah that's what biden did to him
imagine what obama would have done
well and really if we think about it
hillary clinton really rolled him up and
smoked him too it's just the electoral
college got in her way and
and her her campaign really didn't do
their electoral math
um in my opinion i i don't i don't think
hillary clinton
quote unquote did anything wrong i just
think her campaign did the electoral
math wrong
and didn't figure that wisconsin would
matter michigan would matter
pennsylvania wouldn't matter as much
they knew pennsylvania would matter
because they went there in the end
but they they they didn't do the math in
michigan and wisconsin and ohio and that
really hurt them
that was the that was the one time swing
and then look at this election
those states came back right well and
don't you believe
uh you know not to get too in the woods
with this voting uh thing but
don't you believe that more states are
blue than what what actually is shown
i mean absolutely yeah i mean we have
georgia to show that i mean that's
evidence
that morse texas is probably blue blue
ohio's
definitely probably blue i think
michigan pennsylvania is definitely blue
uh florida is probably redder than what
we want to admit but i think it is blue
as well you know
it's kind of purple but it shows ohio's
more red than we want to admit
well that that that may be too you're
you're closer to ohio than i am so
uh you know as the bird as the crow
flies
so but you know um so let's let's move
on to a little different
subjects here because i want to get
through a few things that are in the
news today
since i've got you on here i definitely
want your opinion because i i know
people are going to want to hear your
opinion on these subjects
and you're probably going to be making
videos about this stuff today or
tomorrow
uh this me too movement has uh has
upheaved again
with the news today there's several
different things in news number one bill
cosby was released from prison today
um some of the facts on that is that the
uh pennsylvania supreme court over
overturned his charge
and what happened was is the testimony
that they used in his civil case
um they deemed
inadmissible in other words and i don't
know if you remember but but there was a
lawyer from pennsylvania that defended
trump and his imp his second impeachment
trial you remember this jackass i forget
his name because you ever get his name
as well
but you remember this jackass you know
what i'm talking about all kinds of
dumb [ __ ] he said in the impeachment
trial that's the prosecutor
that's the guy who made the deal with
bill cosby in the civil case if he came
in and gave his testimony
sorry about the light yeah and now your
problem is that the new prosecutor
didn't abide by the old
agreement right so because they used
that in court and the judge allowed it
now the supreme court saying no
the worst part about the whole thing the
worst part about the whole thing is now
now bill cosby will not be able to be
charged again
apparently this crime no right so now
now um i i believe his
his reputation is now irreparable in
repair they cannot
he cannot repair his reputation at this
point uh it still does not mean that
that piece of
sludge should be out and walking about
amongst
other decent human beings uh because he
wasn't exonerated
there's a lot of people saying he was
exonerated he was not exonerated
it was just a piece of evidence that
made him guilty where he said yes i did
this i did this i did this
it was inadmissible in court and the
supreme court decided that and they
overturned his charge
he's so literally walking on a
technicality that's right
so let's let's be clear on that now in
the same me too movement we have
uh a story that is kind of obscure here
we were talking about it to begin with
it was allison mack
she is an actress on smallville
which i never watched smallville and i
really don't know who the hell alice and
mack is to be honest with you
but i have heard of this nexium cult and
they're kind of a sex slave cult i guess
it was some dude who was uh using
famous people and and uh influential
people on social media to attract
young women to his cult or his group
they were supposed to be some sort of
empowerment group or some [ __ ] i watched
the documentary on it
it's very confusing what the hell it was
even about it seemed like a
like an mlm almost like a multi uh uh
multi-level marketing thing it was a
little weird
um but she was charged with three years
and what she was doing apparently was
recruiting
these young women and she knowingly was
recruiting them to be in this sex cult
called nexium
and they were you know sexually
assaulting these people is what they
were doing and
trapping them in a cult even one woman
uh reported
that she was branded on her genitals
with a brand
like a hot iron yeah so it's um that
that's in the news with me too the other
thing that's that's causing this me too
um news to to break is quentin tarantino
was on
joe rogan's podcast uh talk
here we go with joe rogan again you know
the white guy who says i
no one will listen to me because i'm a
white dude here he is trending again
trending again mr mr podcast is trending
again
so quentin tarantino talks about harvey
weinstein are you familiar with the guy
named harvey weinstein
yeah a little bit right so um
harvey weinstein uh we all know what
harvey weinstein
did um sort of the level of bill cosby
where he used his influence to
you know uh let's be just be a gross
horrible monster towards other human
beings is what it is
let's let's be frank about it but uh
quentin tarantino basically says on the
show i went and watched the clip to make
sure i was correct
before we got on here and quentin
tarantino basically says oh i wish i
would have done something
yeah yeah well everyone wishes you would
have done something
but i don't know what do you think about
this me too stuff this bill cosby this
quentin tarantino
i mean well you know what first of all
if you wish you would have done
something that are you admitting that
you knew something then
right you know because if you're saying
that you wish you would have done
something
then you're telling us that you actually
knew something was going on back then
and if you knew something was going on
back then then you're a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] for not doing anything
period i mean that's the way that bottom
day if you're basically just admitting
that yeah yeah we all knew this was
going on and in hindsight
i really knew it was bad [ __ ] you
[ __ ] how many how many women were
assaulted because of this guy and
because you kept your [ __ ] mouth shut
well you know the thing is is in the
clip in the clip from the show from the
joe rogan podcast
he actually says well i didn't know it
was to the extent that it was
right you know he tries to let himself
off the hook but
he's he he does the whole you remember
the grab him by the [ __ ]
right you remember this it's locker room
talk
right it's a locker room so he kind of
plays it off as oh this is how hollywood
operated
and you know all this you know just
tells me that there's a whole lot of
people out there that know a whole lot
of secrets
if you know you got hymns in an
interview basically just sitting there
going
yeah listen this is kind of how we all
know everything operates over here but
you know we understand
now looking back it was bad and this
whole [ __ ] you were just saying
about how
well i didn't know it was to that extent
if you knew of one girl that was
assaulted by harvey weinstein and you
didn't say anything
you're a piece of [ __ ] well i'm i mean
and you're culpable to some degree
yeah yeah you kept your mouth shut while
crying was going on
i don't care if you didn't know it was
to the extent that you will ultimately
found out
what you knew bad [ __ ] was going on
right you kept your mouth shut
right it's not like people were stealing
20 bills
yeah he was raping people exactly
and and he was in his position of power
to do so
right right so so so there's a lot of
the me too
news today it kind of all piled on top
of itself um
i don't i don't think it's designed that
way but it just happened that way that a
lot of these stories broke
uh today with the bill cosby the allison
mack story and then the harvey weinstein
so
it does tend to happen in bunches well
you know i
i think um in in our world it's always
happened that way with social media
though it just it amplifies it
um and then you get people like me and
you who comment make videos and
and tweet and that sort of thing and it
amplifies it even more right i mean
that's just
it you know it spreads it pretty fast
which i think is the design
uh you know we we should we should be
amplifying some of these stories
otherwise we wouldn't hear about them we
wouldn't know about this stuff
everyone's like oh
i don't want to talk about that ah it's
on social media i don't want to talk
about
well what the hell are you going to talk
about then you know what if something
was going around in your town in your
neighborhood back in the day your mom
talked to the neighbor about it the
neighbor talked to your mom about it
that's all social media is is that
everybody can talk to everybody about it
now
so it's up to you to have a little bit
of common sense and weed out the dumb
[ __ ]
and just stick to the people who
actually know what the hell they're
talking about
you know that's that's why i i'm not
much on on facebook
is because i that you know facebook is
like the people you know um
and twitter tick tock is people that
maybe you want to know
right and there's a difference between
people that you know and the people that
you may want to know
yeah family and friends that's what
facebook is for right right right right
so let's let's get back to um uh
the the trump organization because i
want to i want to finish there because
we got about uh
we got about 20 25 minutes and i know i
know there's plenty of time to pick
uh the trump organization apart here
and i know you were talking about the
trump children
and how how you think that they're going
to flip you also brought up
michael cohen which i think is a really
good case study and how this is going to
all turn out
and what i mean by that is um they are
pressuring alan weisselberg here
rather rather trump or trump
organization or anyone trump allies
want to admit it or not uh it's obvious
that alan weiserberg has not flipped
or to some degree has not flipped enough
that's why they're going to charge him
and the trump organization
is because he is the cfo um they are the
trump organization
and he works for the trump organization
so when they charge them and i'm not
really sure of new york state law and
again i'm not an attorney but
i believe that's going to cause a lot of
problems inside their company
yeah i i don't i don't believe that he's
going to have be able to be an operating
officer while he's being indicted
and the companies being indicted on tax
fraud in the state of new york because
they are a new york business
he is an officer of a corporation in the
state of new york
so i would guess they have a little bit
of say on whether
weisselberg can remain the cfo of an
organization that is criminally charged
in the same case he's charged in
it sounds like that's where the
pressure's coming from what do you think
i think the pressure is coming because
uh alan weiselberg's been the cfo of
that organization since trump's father
ran the organization
and trump's father was the king at
crooked business dealings
he taught his son very well um
the and so as a result alan weisselberg
handled here's the bottom line on cfos
how long does the average cfo stick
around with the company
some people say it's anywhere from seven
to ten years before
the the relationship wears people need
fresh starts
and the cfos move on to another company
or the company moves on from that cfo
he's been the cfo since papa trump
decades
why because the trump organization has
always done things
below board crookedly
illegally and he was the one that knew
how to
move the money around in a crooked
manner for them to hide it
for them for all these decades so what
they're going to do is they're going to
go after him
first they don't have to go after the
lawyer because they already got the
lawyer
the lawyer already went to prison and he
spilled everything he's working with
them
they're going to go after the money man
first they're going to pressure him so
that he opens up the books
and then everybody that had their hand
in ownership in that country which is
trump
company which is trump and his kids will
be brought in
and charged equally and i believe
they're going to use the old
statute the rico statute they use the
old rico statute which is designed to go
after
organized crime because organized crime
members conspire together to commit
crimes
which is what the trump organization did
for decades
once they get them all with rico what
that means if one person committed a
crime within the organization
everybody within the organization can be
charged with that crime
so weisselberg moved the numbers around
everybody gets charged with that well
weisselberg's then going to turn around
i believe and say
i was ordered to do that i work for them
i believe trump's going to turn around
go hey wait a minute i rely on my
lawyers and my accountants
you know i just know how to do my
business you know i know how to get
people to come into a casino you don't
you're too [ __ ] stupid to know that
but anyway and that's what he's gonna
try and say and then it's gonna come
down to the kids
and the kids are going to have to decide
whether or not they're going to go to
jail for
papa or if they're going to roll on papa
because they're going to have
i believe they already have enough
evidence to charge the whole lot of them
i believe they're leaning on people to
get them to flip one at a time
and i believe they're all gonna flip so
i i
i think i think a lot of what you say is
correct uh
now i did a little bit of research on
the ricoh act
uh the the ricoh act is uh the actual
ricoh
is federal law which they use in federal
courts this is in the manhattan d8
now the state of new york after rico
after they decided
the feds decided that they could use
rico to really bang up
organized crime uh you know in the late
70s early 80s
uh the state of new york also passed
their own rico law
which they were for it's it's i forget
the acronym but they call it little rico
yeah it's because it's kind of the same
thing right
now i think actually where
a lot of the pressure is going to come
from alan weisselberg and the kids
is alan weisselberg and ivanka trump and
the reason why
is because they have this little thing
that they're investigating the in the
2016 inauguration
trump's inauguration committee um
there's a lot of money that seems a lot
of reporters
uh david farrenhold is one of them uh
that out there are trying to find where
this money went
like where the hell did this money go
where is it
there was a lot of money it's gone where
did it go
um so i think i think that is
also some of the pressure that's gonna
happen because what i believe
is that the manhattan d.a number one
their main goal
is to absolutely destroy the trump
organization they know
they know that they're committing crimes
either it's tax fraud money laundering
whatever those crimes may be
and they have the evidence to to destroy
the trump organization
um and and and really cut donald trump
down at his knees
whether he goes to prison or not that's
one thing he's going to lose his
livelihood
here that that that that almost is for
certain
him and his kids are gonna just like
bernie madoff lost their livelihood
i believe donald trump's gonna lose his
livelihood here and his children and
possibly his grandchildren
um so that i i believe that's a
manhattan da's main
uh objective of the probe is to destroy
the trump organization because they know
it's a
they know it's company of crime they
know yeah
so the entire organization is crooked
and they're gonna seize every last bit
of it break it up into pieces and sell
it off
you know and and i think i think it will
like i said earlier it'd be a good thing
in this country if there's not a
building with the name trump on it
absolutely unless you know maybe it's
you know
uh something other than donald trump and
his family you know maybe another trump
family maybe maybe one day sadly we'll
have the trump presidential library
well yeah let me tell you something a
coloring book factory isn't necessarily
a library but you know
we will we will work through that
situation
but the other thing about the the case
out of the manhattan da's that's got me
completely interested
and i think you touched on this a little
bit is with the kids
um is that i think that's where their
probe is is not just the organization
but also the federal referrals
um because i believe truly it's going to
be very hard
for a federal court to put a former
president
in a federal prison that is going to be
very difficult
it's never happened i don't think the
system has ever wanted it to happen and
what i mean by that
systematically the system is designed
not to put a president or a former
president
in a federal prison i can't argue with
that it is designed that way
they want to keep it that way because we
put one former president
in federal prison who's gonna want you
know it's that whole [ __ ] who's gonna
want to be president thing which is not
the truth it's not reality
right but let's face it it's 20 21 and
we still don't live in reality here and
at least half of us don't
well there's there's a large majority
that live on mars here
so so i believe though the one thing
that the manhattan d.a wants to do is
they want to
produce federal referrals for federal
crimes
through these probes of the trump
organization weisselberg
ivanka trump i think it's gonna create a
huge federal probe
when we're talking about uh the
inauguration committee because that
that gets into federal crimes and
federal court
um but but do you think back to the
trump going to prison because i'm very
interested in hearing everyone's opinion
on this
because i'm very unsure about it i i
really that's the thing i don't know
i do know trump is a criminal i do know
they will charge him with crimes i do
know that he will probably receive a
conviction somewhere
whether it's in a new york federal
criminal court
a federal criminal court a georgia
criminal court an arizona federal
there's all kinds of courts that he
could be tied up in with criminal
charges
but what does it look like to you if a
former president
is incarcerated what do you think that
looks like
uh looks like john gotti getting let
into prison
i i think new york's gonna get him i
think that they've been committing
crimes for decades and it's all
documented and when i say decades i mean
since the 70s
easily which is the reason why no bank
in america will lend to this family
or this company it's the reason why they
got to go to russia for all their money
it's the reason why they've admitted
to going to russia prior to daddy ever
thinking about politics
very seriously that they go to russia
for their money because they've been
crooked for years
and it's all documented somebody has to
keep the numbers straight
even in a crooked organization enter the
lawyer and the accountant
the guy who handles the numbers and the
guy who cleans up everything for you
well the guy who cleans up everything
for you is already telling everything he
knows
and now it's up to the guy who handles
all your numbers to determine whether or
not he's going to go to prison
for a lifetime of your crimes so if i'm
trump i'm [ __ ] egg rolls
and once weisselberg flips which i
believe is going to happen
like i said all of the ownership is
going to have a decision to make as to
whether or not they're going
and i think one by one they're all going
to flip on them and i think eventually
once the whole world is turned on trump
he's going to have no
there's going to be a mountain of
evidence so so compelling
they're going to have no choice but to
put him in prison like they do every
big time high-profile mobster in new
york it's gonna be the same type of
thing now i honestly believe they're
gonna
catch him trying to flee the country and
if he does actually go to prison i don't
think he's gonna last too long given his
age
health and relative unpopular state but
um
yeah i actually do believe he's going to
get caught and go to prison i'd say
within three to four years
everything trump touches turns to liquid
[ __ ] that's for sure
yeah uh uh what's his name uh i forget
the other rick wilson said everything
trump touches died guys yeah i
i like liquid [ __ ] because you know the
whole diaper dawn thing yeah true
true you know everything he touches
turns to liquid [ __ ]
liquid [ __ ] but but uh
you know speaking of everything trump
touches turns to liquid [ __ ]
uh and him going to prison and and all
this stuff
so so if trump goes to prison and
trump's towed it off like you're saying
like john gotti
surely we're gonna see eric don jr
ivanka have their chance
rather they're going to have the perp
walk or not like you were saying do they
flip do they not flip
so do you are you predicting are you
predicting that they flip
on dad or do you pull or you think that
dad flips on them
uh all of the above i think dad flips on
everybody and tries to pin it on
everybody around him
as everybody around him flips on him i
think weisselberg's gonna look at him go
i'm not going to prison for this
i'm too old there's no way in hell i'm
dying in prison and so he flipped so now
they got the accountant and the lawyer
they start working their way through the
kids as i said i think ivanka takes a
look at her life and says i can still
have a pretty nice life
and not go to prison so why am i going
to prison for his [ __ ] they're
already distancing themselves
the reports are out that they're trying
to distance themselves from daddy
already so i believe she flips and says
yeah it was all him
i believe eric flips and tries to play
stupid well i didn't know what was going
on well that won't be hard
right exactly and as i've stated in
multiple pieces of content i'll try to
be delicate with this
i think that the pressure gets too great
for don jr and he chooses another way
out
well i mean obviously if don jr doesn't
choose that way out he definitely will
snort that way out because
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] and therein lies a
telltale sign of his current state
because when people
are backed into a corner and they
realize it's all over
and they don't know what to do what do
they start doing they start doing all
kinds of
self-harming behavior sometimes they
start living it up because they know
this is the last run for them
and i think that's what we're seeing
with junior he's in the throes of that
kind of
breakneck pace world of [ __ ] i don't
know what's going on
because it's all falling apart so do you
so do you think
do you think for don jr because because
man i've watched some of
and i can't watch it very long because
it's just a [ __ ] train wreck
um and i don't have that kind of time to
pay attention to that [ __ ]
just enough here i'll give you a secret
so i've got a video out there called
booger sugar and i'll tell
everyone out there i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ]
why don junior is trending on on twitter
i do not give two [ __ ] shits
why he is twinning trending on twitter
the i love when don jr
trends on twitter and the only reason
why is so i can play my booger sugar
diddy that is it that is the only reason
why i like it everyone knows it as soon
as he's trending
i post that [ __ ] i don't care
because i
i i i it it it encapsulates him
beautifully i think
of course it's my content you know so
i'm gonna put it out there but
but don jr do you think do you think
it's the criminal aspect of this or do
you think it's the financial aspect of
this
that that has really got this guy i mean
because man he
i i would not i would not put it past
him that he's laying down in a
king-sized bed full of coke right now
yeah i think it's both and that's what i
was talking about when i was talking
about the alternative way out i think he
obviously chooses that neither option
are good for him because i think he's
looking right now at
holy [ __ ] i either have to go to prison
which is not i've died there's no
[ __ ] way
no one wants to go to prison no one or i
have to turn on dad
watch the empire crumble and go get a
[ __ ] job
which he can't do either so i don't
think he likes either option
right do you think that's but do you
think that's why so many people were so
desperate for this [ __ ] to
remain president
do you think that's why and what i mean
by so many people i mean these peop
these people close to him his family
uh uh some of these can like rudy
giuliani i mean jesus christ there's a
whole another goddamn podcast we can
talk about
when we talk about crime and corruption
but rudy giuliani
uh jason miller stephen miller uh if if
this inauguration committee happens i
mean he already pardoned one person for
the inauguration
[ __ ] thing that that big donor i mean
i mean so
there's there's so many components
matt gatz that motherfucker's under
federal indictment and apparently
the reports are that joel greenberg was
trying to pay roger stone there's
another goddamn name
he was trying to pay roger stone 250 000
to go cam to go lobby uh jared kushner
and then rudy giuliani to go lobby to
the president of the united states at
the time donald trump for a pardon
and you seen you seen the evidence
because on on january 17th i did a video
about rudy giuliani going to the white
house and i made a joke about him
carrying a napkin in the white house
that had the names
of the people he wanted pardon and i
said it's just got his [ __ ] name on
it it's just his name
but uh now i believe that he not only
had joel greenberg's name but he had a
whole list of people
that needed to be pardoned and and maybe
their secret pardons maybe there's not i
guess we'll find that out
how that works and even if it works or
if there's a thing like that
but but i i there's there is so
there is so many names so many
indictments so many people do you think
that's why these people were [ __ ]
desperate i mean
desperate to incite even to incite an
insurrection to cause a coup
to make sure that this person remained
president
some yeah now see i don't think like his
family members necessarily
were all like the kids were all part of
the coup thing
uh you could tell like the ivanka's and
the erics are like these this guy's
[ __ ] losing it with this
uh but some people yes they were
desperate for him to remain in office
because they needed the shielding and
the coverage that the power brought
other people lindsey graham
this dude ron johnson out of wisconsin
people like that
they were desperate i believe because if
you remember in 2016 the republican
national committee admitted openly
and the russians didn't deny that the
russians did hack
both the dnc and the rnc servers
but not one piece of information ever
came out about a single republican
so you're telling me the republicans are
100
putin putin gave it to his boy
because putin knows how to handle donald
trump
trump has whatever the russians found on
those [ __ ] servers
to use as leverage over the republican
party
to fall in line all four years why the
[ __ ] do you think somebody like lindsey
graham goes from
if we nominate this guy it'll destroy
our party and we'll [ __ ] deserve it
to
we donald trump must remain in power at
all costs
because he's got something on lindsey
graham that the russians found when they
got the rnc server
so you're saying you're saying that
that vladimir putin vladimir putin
ran roughshod and chao agents of chaos
with donald trump
is that what you're saying because
that's what i hear you saying absolute
[ __ ] lutely through roger stone
yeah well and do you think do you think
i i i have thought this for a long time
when we watched him
ascend down that stupid [ __ ] gold
escalator
and get up in front of a microphone and
puke racist [ __ ] into a microphone to
get to
to act like he was running because he
was acting like he was running for
president he wasn't actually running for
president at that point
do you think that vladimir putin
this is just this is not news i'm just
surmising here
do you think vladimir putin said hey go
do this thing i will let you have a
trump tower
do you think that's a possibility
honestly i don't think that's the
possibility
i think that trump saw running for
president
as kind of a way to get back at obama
but really a way to kind of boost his
brand and once he gained traction
because
nobody thought he was going to nobody
not a [ __ ] well there was a cuban
[ __ ]
but they weren't serious they weren't
serious if they thought he was even his
most
loyal supporters in the white house
kellyanne conway talked about what a
joke he was during the election
his own press secretary mcinerney botox
barbie
she talked about what a [ __ ] joke he
was they all talked about what a joke he
was
so nobody took him serious but once he
started to gain traction
because he was in bed with putin i think
that's when putin was like
hey okay now you're doing something
now we're going to give you some help
now we're going to go ahead and start
hacking servers
i don't think it was set up with putin i
think it was all trump like just trying
to
beat trump boost his brand so what
you're saying is he fell
ass backwards into being president
literally yes
right and and when he became president
it was obvious because
the the scariest moment to me and why
it'd be
scary is you could tell he was
frightened
is when he won that night and he came
out on stage
to accept it he was not the same donald
trump
like it was like oh my god this was not
the plan
yeah the plan the plan was not for me to
have to get a job and work
that was not the plan no that was not
all a marketing ploy
and that was like uh very similar to
that sound you hear on tick tock
oh i [ __ ] up
always with the tick tock with you tick
tockers
do you get that kind of [ __ ] oh oh you
mr grown man tick tocker i'm like you're
on
tick tock you're [ __ ] on
tick tock talk telling me
what the [ __ ] how do you think you watch
videos yeah i have a lot of young people
telling me to get the [ __ ] off the air
right
yeah well you know [ __ ] them [ __ ] up
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em indeed well i appreciate you
joining me today and there's one other
thing that i want to talk about before
we leave
uh because we are close to the fourth of
july and it's patriotism
and what it means now after the
insurrection of course you know after
september 11th happened patriotism means
a whole new thing in this country
for a whole new generation now after
january 6 a whole new generation has to
evaluate what the [ __ ] patriotism is
again
i've always believed that patriotism
isn't actually a great
great thing i think it can lead to very
bad
uh delusional things when you are so
deluded that your country is the
greatest thing ever no matter what
no matter what it does what it's done in
the past or what it can do or what it
should do
i think sometimes patriotism well most
of the time it's not a [ __ ] good
thing
you should love your country you should
love for your country to get better
and but when it's bad you should say
it's bad and when it's been horrible you
should [ __ ] own up to it and not lie
about it
that's my opinion but i want to hear i
want to hear since it's coming close to
fourth of july i'd like to hear what you
think about patriotism and what it means
now
after we've had uh maga these q anon
[ __ ] trump being present and mostly the
insurrection
well i think that with what we're
currently facing
with the insurrectionist wave in the
maga people the the modern day fascists
that are in this country i think what we
need to return to
without all of the racism and sexism i
think we need to return to
our founding days and what i mean by
that is
terminology that we don't talk about
anymore because
everybody's out there talking about this
side that side this side that side
and the mangas are beating the [ __ ]
liberals over the head with their
[ __ ] trumps coming back trump's
coming back [ __ ] but
we got to get back to the founding work
we the people
we the people in god we trust is not
our nation's motto e pluribus unum is
out of many one instead of beating each
other over the head with this [ __ ]
faux patriotism and actually trying to
overturn a country why don't we get back
to
we the people in order to form a more
perfect union we're constantly trying to
strive
to form a more perfect union that
includes
everybody here and everybody that wants
to come here
that's how we became the country we are
so
stop with the we're the greatest on the
on the planet and everybody else can go
[ __ ] themselves because
last time i checked everybody else came
here and helped make this country what
it is
[ __ ] fantastic and let's make
red hats wearable again the other thing
that i want to do
with this patriotism because he
destroyed red hats he [ __ ] destroyed
rit they destroyed
destroyed [ __ ] destroyed wearing a
red hat
the other thing they destroyed by
humping it and putting his picture on it
and his name
is the [ __ ] american flag we need to
take that
seriously i i see people you know right
now it's fourth of july and they got
american flags everywhere and it kind of
grosses me out
it kind of grosses me out i'm like man i
get i i'm so tired of
a last four years of these people
draping the flag over themselves and
like you said this faux patriotism this
[ __ ] line of
i have a flag so i'm a patriot
it's just all nonsense you don't even
know what the flag means i mean jesus
christ
an olympian an olympian an american
olympian who is a black female a black
woman
turns her back on the national anthem
with a shirt that says
athlete activist she wasn't hiding what
she was doing
turns her back so she can peacefully
peacefully
peacefully protest and you have [ __ ]
captain eyepatch
dan crenshaw get a [ __ ] glass eye
would you please
[ __ ] talking about how she
shouldn't be on the olympic team because
he's too weak to watch her turn her back
on the american flag
give me a [ __ ] break you [ __ ] but
he wasn't
he wasn't too weak to watch people on
his side of the aisle use an american
flag attached to a pole
to beat a capital police officer over
the head that was trying to protect him
it's not about the flag it's about wins
and losses
did my side win so if he can make the
other side bad
it's a win for his side that's all that
matters he didn't say [ __ ]
about the american flag that was on the
ground on the steps of the capitol
right you have one [ __ ] word to say
about that flag or the desecration that
they did to the capital and what it
the flag that it represents but colin
kaepernick
colin kaepernick if he kneels during the
national anthem by god it is the most
and he's against the military and it's
anti-military and it's anti-american
actually it is it is american there's
nothing more american
than giving a big [ __ ] you to american
patriotism
that's the whole reason why we're here
in the first place is liberty
liberty because i love what you said
about we the people
because i believe that we strive in this
country for liberty
and the vehicle that we get to liberty
is freedom and
rights and the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people
is not liberty it's not
and here he with the we the people
you know what i'm gonna start going on a
tangent you ain't got that much time no
go ahead we got a few more minutes
everybody talks about how the government
can't take this the government can't do
this the government
we are the [ __ ] government read the
document
we the people the government didn't give
us rights
god didn't give us rights we gave
ourselves rights
we can alter our rights we can choose
how we want to govern ourselves
everybody looks at government as an evil
entity well guess what
dumbass look in the mirror you're the
government
right it's not some big [ __ ] building
they say big government as if they're
adding on to a building
and adding on to a building and it's
full of like robots or some
entity that's not part of what we are
right
so they were those they're there because
we put them there
right we elect well sort of i mean yeah
depending on how your your [ __ ]
districts gerrymandered
speaking speaking of gerrymandering and
dan crenshaw
you know what have you seen a picture of
that motherfucker's gerrymandered
district
dangerous but i have of jim jordan's and
i live in a gerrymandered district so so
so
dan crenshaw's [ __ ] and i don't know
if this is the reason why
i'm just surmising here i i i i have no
evidence of this
but dan crenshaw's if you go look at the
map and you look at a picture of this
motherfucker's gerrymandered district
that son of a [ __ ] looks like an eye
patch
his [ __ ] district looks like a
goddamn eye patch it [ __ ] looks like
an eye patch
damn crinchoff you can hear me get a
[ __ ] glass eye for
crying out loud get the eyepatch off no
one feels
sorry check it out go look at it just
google dan crenshaw's
uh district it'll it looks it looks like
a [ __ ] eye patch it's crazy will do
well hey man i appreciate you coming on
a podcast and i'll have to have you come
back on again because i
i really like to dive more into this
patriotism and even religion with you
because i know you got a lot to say
about a
religion or lack thereof or well however
you want to
so thanks for coming on i really
appreciate uh hang around
i'll get you on the other side but i
want to let these people go thanks
thanks tom
no problem we'll have him back everybody
holy moly
tom powell jr the tick tocker
the author the podcaster go check his
podcast out
go check his tick tock out uh you can't
find him on twitter because uh you know
they they got him on a lifetime ban they
they track his ip and
shut him down you heard that uh but but
go find him
go find him on the tiki talks uh he's
got it and i'm sure he's got all his
stuff with his books and his podcast
over there so
go listen to him uh maybe maybe i'll be
on his podcast i don't know if he does
that or not if you guys guess and maybe
i'll yell and scream on there and then
and then i can link to it and you guys
can see his podcast
but thank you for joining us today live
we're over just a little bit but again i
want to tell you you guys have seen the
red hat
there's a new red [ __ ] hat and
there's blue and we're going to keep the
gray and the black
so i appreciate you guys supporting the
podcast with your likes
your comments your shares uh subscribing
to the youtube channel do that kind of
[ __ ] you know what whatever it is
subscribe follow
whatever the hell that [ __ ] is just do
that stuff but if you want to support
the podcast
so we can keep it going you can buy a
[ __ ] hat we got [ __ ] stickers
just go to thetonymichaels.com it's all
there and
and don't worry if you don't like
watching my ugly mug
you can go download this podcast on
apple podcast
on spotify all the directories that you
want you just pick one
that son of a [ __ ] should be on there
and if it's not message me i'll try to
get
get it on whatever obscure directory
that you're on
but go listen to it on the podcast
directories join us here on youtube
every wednesday three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern
and i got a little bit of news that i
want to go over
we're going to be start doing some
special guest podcasts these guest
podcasts always do really good you guys
always really like them
and i want to keep doing the live show
but i think what we're going to do is
we're going to start recording our
special guest podcast and airing them on
a different day
so there's going to be some weeks where
you get two podcasts
the live podcast like today and a rep
recorded podcast with a special guest
because i always like to have guests on
like tom
last week was one black man's opinion
michael j
and we've had michael j on a few times
i'm trying to get a few more guests
and if you're out there listening
respond to my email
respond to my email so thank you for
joining us today
i'll see you next week remember three
o'clock central four o'clock eastern and
until then
until then [ __ ] em you've been listening
to the tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them